(car rumbling)
(people chattering)
(boy speaks in foreign language)
(soldiers shout)
(whistle blows)
(people speak in foreign language)
(dramatic music)
- My name is Jonas Poher Rasmussen
and I'm the director of "Flee,"
an animated documentary
about a friend of mine
who I met when I was 15
and a physical fight going
from Afghanistan to Denmark.
But it's even more so
about an internal fight,
about a man who has had to
flee himself all his life.
When he was a young man in Afghanistan
he couldn't be openly gay,
so he kinda had to hide that away.
And then he arrived in Denmark
and all of a sudden he
had to hide his past.
And also it's a story
about memory and trauma.
(dramatic music)
(clapperboard clacks)
The scene we're about to go into
is from the end of the film,
and at this point he came out
with his story about his past,
he told us about how he came
from Afghanistan to Denmark,
and just afterwards now
he has to tell his family
about him being gay and they accept him.
All of a sudden everything is out
and so the celebration at the gay bar
is really about him finally
being in a place in the world
where he can be who he is,
you know, with his sexuality,
but also with his past.
(chain clinks)
(woman speaks in foreign language)
(Amin speaks in foreign language)
- [Jonas] So this is a good sequence
where Amin is asking for
medicine for being gay.
You know, he doesn't see it as a disease
but he thought it was
something that you could cure,
and actually Amin was really embarrassed
by this part in the film
and asked me if that
needed to be in there,
so we had a long conversation about that
'cause I thought it was so
important to have that in
because to kind of really
understand where he came from
and how suppressed his sexuality was.
(woman speaks in foreign language)
- [Jonas] The lady who he's talking to
worked at this asylum center.
Here the voice is
actually made by my wife.
(woman speaks in foreign language)
(Amin speaks in foreign language)
- She was right next to me
so I asked her if she could do the lines,
and they actually kind
of look alike as well.
So the animation style we chose for "Flee"
was really being as authentic as possible,
so it's really inspired by the landscapes
from just around the area where I grew up.
We recognize the fields
and the farms and hills.
But it was really about
trying to support his voice,
we were listening carefully,
and do a lot of research.
And here it's Denmark,
close to my hometown.
We did like a big art bible
of powerful references from
different visual artists.
So one was Edward Hopper.
There's this certain sense
of solitude in his images
that we really wanted to have in there
'cause Amin's story is really a story
about solitude as well,
about loneliness, about not
being able to be honest.
And we felt that in
Edward Hopper's paintings,
that there is this sense of solitude.
(Amin speaks in foreign language)
(woman speaks in foreign language)
- [Jonas] Here he kinda started realizing
at some point I would
have to tell my family,
and he was quite certain
that they wouldn't be able to accept it
because it wasn't
acceptable in Afghanistan
and in the culture in general.
So this sequence really
plays on, you know,
his own prejudice against his own family
and I think most other people's prejudices
against how gay people are received
in Muslim families and countries.
And I really wanted to have that in there,
you know, the sense of okay
but this is not gonna go well.
We worked in this software in animation
that's called Shotgun,
so every shot has a number and a name,
and then the animating director
who did the artwork and me
we would each kind of of write
what's going on in every shot.
So in a shot like this one
I would kind of write where
the family is heading.
It's the first time
they're together for years
and we should feel kind of the comfort
of him being with his family
but also quite fast feel
that he's annoyed with his older brother.
Here he's teasing and here Amin is afraid
and annoyed at the same time.
And then the animating
director could use that
for the direction for the animators
to kind of make it look like it.
So, of course, when we see
how his brother looks at him
afterwards he said that he's
not interested in girls,
that look is because of his fear,
again, it's because of Amin's prejudice
and what he thinks his brother thinks,
and we wanted to have that in there.
In this specific scene,
we zoom in on Amin, he's in the car,
and he is realizing that now
I said it, now it's goodbye,
I have to live my life from
now on without my family.
So here we kind of decided
to have these flashbacks
and he would start to
recall everything in detail.
Using these cinematic tools,
using that pull and stretch,
like really stretch time at times
so you feel okay now time stands still
because this is a crucial moment,
and really using that
and feel the pressure
that he was under
because he carried this
thing around that he was gay
and he didn't think that his family
would be able to accept it.
So in order to give the audience
just a little bit of sense of relief,
of that sense of relief that he felt
when he finally came out
and he understood that they
actually did accept him,
and when Amin walks down
the corridor towards the bar
he himself knows that it's
not a brothel or a strip club,
but we wanted to keep the information
that the family had accepted him
until the very last second.
(gentle music)
When I write, I always listen to music
and I have different playlists.
Often, it's non-verbal music,
like electronic, classical,
different kinds of music.
And as I was kind of transcribing
and working on this sequence
I was listening to a playlist
and this Daft Punk song came on.
That song really starts
when really on the moment
where you get this sense of solitude,
that now he's on his own,
and he's kind of saying goodbye
to all the good things he had,
all the support he had from his family
and all the good memories he had.
And it just felt like a perfect
fit from the very beginning
and I had this kind of feeling of okay
this needs to be in there
because it had this sense of loneliness,
and this sequence is really about
Amin feeling all alone in the world
and this song has this
kind of shift as well
where it kind of turns
into more of a party song.
(gentle music)
(people cheering)
(upbeat music)
So it just felt like the perfect match
and then it was just the struggle
of getting the rights to use it,
and I just kind of hunted down
Daft Punk for three years,
I think they must have been
really annoyed at the end.
But in the end they saw
the clip and loved it.
I think it was one of the biggest release
of making this film, actually,
to get that song.
(people cheering)
(upbeat music)
(bartender speaks in foreign language)
- [Jonas] And the gay
bar is really inspired
by some of the gay bars we went to,
and specifically one in Copenhagen,
but also the specific one that he went to.
So it's kind of a mix
of different gay bars
but it's really for me inspired by
a lot of the parties we went to together
and by a lot of gay bars
we went to together.
And of course the bartender
is a little bit inspired
by Jean-Claude Van Damme
because I wanted to add
his lifetime crush in there
just to kind of show that it was okay
for him to feel attracted
to someone like Jean-Claude Van Damme.
(people cheering)
(Amin speaks in foreign language)
(Amin laughs)
- [Jonas] In the very last
part of this sequence,
we see him disappear in a crowd
and finally he is in a place
in the world, you know,
where he is safe, he doesn't
have to flee anymore,
and he can be openly gay,
and it really concludes the film
about this guy who's had
to run away from things
all of his life
and now he can be who he is.
And that's kind of where, you know,
the main theme of the film ends.
This story is really about
sharing and listening
and the healing powers of sharing,
and it was just a slow process
of kind of going deeper and
deeper into these memories,
and then of course choosing
the parts that worked
because this story expands
for more than 30 years,
so it was really about finding, okay,
but what's the core of this?
And then trying to figuring out
what part of his testimony
needs to be in the film
and how these experiences
have marked him for life.
And then finding archival footage
and finding a style of animating
that could support that.
But all the time in the core was
listening to the voice,
listening to what was being said,
really listening carefully
to how he said things,
and make sure that we
tried to support that
as good as we could.
(gentle music)